back in san diego for game three the
finale of this three-game series between
the colorado rockies and the san diego
padres
padres and rockies ready to go as a
padres take the field to 90 in san diego
led by zach davies who tonight is
looking for his seventh win of the year
very quietly is six and two
and the padres trying to sweep the
colorado rockies tonight
rymel tapia standing in for the colorado
rockies
and a swing and a miss down to one knee
good start for davey strikes out the
first rocky that he faces in tonight's
game
perfect location great depth and a bad
hack by tapia so one down here in the
first inning brings up trevor story
this ball lifted to deep left field and
trevor story has caught all of it
that hit a pole about 40 feet behind the
wall for trevor's 10th home run of the
year
one nothing colorado just the sixth home
run davies has relinquished this year
this was a bomb one down for charlie
blackmon
and that strike three gets blackman's
second k of the night for zach davies
two down and it locks up blackman on the
bound is antonio sensatella he's ready
to go
he's got a 333 era actually has a
a lower era amazingly at home
just 284 at home two down here in the
first brings up manny machado
lying to left field tapia
can't get it it's by him to the track
and the wall machado is headed for
second base
and a line drive double to the gap in
left center field out of the reach of
rhino tapia and machado in scoring
position with two down that was a rope
to left field
two down machado they're at second base
and here's mitch moreland
in the air to deep right field back goes
blackman at the
mitch moreland has left the building to
right and the padres take a 2-1 lead
welcome to san diego mitch moreland
you go to the second inning with matt
kemp leading it off
swinging a miss and he strikes out kemp
nicely done
back-to-back on the change-ups and kept
just couldn't hit it four strikeouts for
davies one down one down here in the
second inning josh fuentes
strike three call that is five
strikeouts for zach davies two down here
in the second inning and three in a row
he's got two down here in the second
inning here's garrett hampton
swing and a miss and he strikes out
hampson
that is six strikeouts for davies
so back to the first and second go the
rockies runners with two outs
and olin aronado riding a four-game
hitting streak
to left field shallow pro far studded
back now he comes in and he recovers to
make the catch it ends the
inning we play two and a half it's 2-1
padres
here's will myers
pitch to myers swung on hit high in the
air down the right field line blackman
onto the warning track runs into the
wall and makes the catch
reaching across his body
great play by charlie blackmon to retire
myers
on a deep fly to right and kevin pillar
to lead it off here for the rockies
and he struck him out second time the
large down by way of the k seven
strikeouts for zach davies he's amazing
kemp five for 17 in his career against
davies two home runs
that's straight three back-to-back
strikeouts eight in all
second time kev has struck out
two down diaz at first base and here's
trevor story
story chops one to third machado's got
it
and that is that at the top of the fifth
we're halfway through with the padres on
top two one
two down sixth inning or nano at second
base and matt kemp coming up here for
the rockies
and kemp lifts this ball to deep left
center field way back at god
matt kemp has done it again
and the rockies take a three to two lead
i don't know if that was a strike
he took his nine iron out hit it over
the left center field wall here is will
with moreland at first base
now he drives one to the gap in right
center field that will get down and roll
to the track and the wall
moreland headed to third and beyond
they're going to try and score him here
comes the throw it's going to third base
and safe with an rbi triple is will
myers and this game is tied three to
three
vintage will myers
jake cronenworth at the plate
line and that'll get into center field
coming from third is myers and the
padres take a 4-3 lead rbi single for
jake cronenworth puts the padres back on
top
austin nola has been aboard twice
lying to left field a base hit here
comes myers around going to try and
score throw coming playwright is going
to be cut off and the padres take a 5-3
lead austin nola with an insurance rbi
two down ninth inning top of the order
rymel tapia
on the ground right side croniworth will
go to first and the padres will win
tonight
they sweep the series
of the colorado rockies